[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado el día
hablamos de la escuela chilena Emilia
lascar de peñaflor que por la pandemia
como una Que fue premiada mejor dicho
como una de las mejores del mundo en la
categoría de innovación por su programa
familiar TV que aborda temas como la
Salud Mental o la identidad de género y
dónde Los contenidos son creados de
manera colectiva y conjunta entre
docentes y alumnos y también parte de la
comunidad saludamos a Antonio Briones él
es representante de la escuela Emilia
lascar y encargado de la convivencia
Gracias Emilio por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 Cómo
surgió Antonio Perdón Cómo surgió este
este proyecto del que estamos hablando
estaba primero confundido un poco de la
pandemia porque tenía entendido y estaba
leyendo que surgió precisamente de esta
pandemia de covid 19 no
Así es producto de bueno Buenos días
primero que todo muchas gracias por la
invitación producto de la pandemia y
producto de las cuarentenas que se
empezaron a implementar estas
cuarentenas donde a Mitades de marzo
aproximadamente los niños y niñas de
nuestra de nuestro país tuvieron que
estar en sus hogares nosotros
identificamos que hacía falta un espacio
Más allá de las clases virtuales un
espacio donde pudiéramos entregar
momentos de contención apoyo y guía a
nuestras familias y los niños y niñas
producto de las situaciones de ansiedad
y angustias que estaban viviendo
producto de la pandemia y del covid
Incluso en algunos casos algunas
familias tuvieron algunos fallecimientos
al principio de la pandemia por lo tanto
la escuela generó este espacio que se
llama Emilia TV como una manera de poder
primero de todo entregar contención y
posteriormente este espacio se
constituyó en un momento de
participación de toda la comunidad de la
escuela donde los niños y niñas la
familia los profesores etcétera podían
entregar
azul las podían entregar un espacio
creado por ellos mismos y eso fue lo que
constituyó este programa Emilia TV en
tiempos de pandemia Antonio hablemos de
los temas que tratan principalmente como
la Salud Mental también como la
identidad de género como lo desarrollan
Sí la verdad es que son temas que son
parte del del currículum de las escuelas
son temas que deben ser tratados por
nuestras instituciones escolares pero
esta posibilidad de hacerlo a través de
los medios de comunicación a través de
las redes sociales permite de alguna
manera que estos temas puedan ser
trabajados primero que todo desde los
niños y niñas que ellos puedan hablar de
esto desde su mirada desde su visión Y
que además pueda llegar a ellos de una
manera distinta ya que estamos ocupando
la tecnología como un canal como un
recurso como un medio y es algo que sin
duda ellos los cautiva los motiva y los
lleva a poder
generar sus aprendizajes de una manera
en que ellos se sientan parte Cuál ha
sido este crecimiento y desarrollo de
los niños no el cambio positivo de
hablar de esos temas sobre todo como
impacta este canal en la comunidad
Cuáles son no sé si tienen ese dato sus
principales visitantes sus principales
digamos televidentes Por así decirlo no
y qué número de dioncia tienen en
términos de de afluencia en el canal
bueno los primeros los primeros
auditores en las primeras personas que
lo ven son nuestros estudiantes ya que
nosotros hacemos la transmisión por
ejemplo hoy día a las 12:30 tenemos otra
transmisión y la hacemos para todas las
salas de la escuela Se generó un ajuste
curricular que permite que todos los
niños y niñas en el momento en vivo
digamos puedan ver el programa Y además
por supuesto su familias Entonces
tenemos la verdad bastante visita Ese es
el emira te ve creado por niños la otra
parte en la que tiene que ver con la
transmisión en vivo de la vida
institucional que por ejemplo lo que
tenga que ver con el aniversario o
fiestas patrias etcétera ahí hay
tenemos de repente más de 2000 visitas
en los programas También tenemos una una
concurrencia bastante importante porque
lo bueno de que se transmite a través
del canal de YouTube por lo tanto lo
pueden ver una y otra vez y el efecto de
los estudiantes la verdad es que el
principal efecto más que medible Cómo
vemos Nosotros los niños y niñas que
están participando de esta instancia
niños y niñas que en el primer semestre
se veían inhibidos muy tímidos hoy ellos
son capaces de pararse frente a una
cámara son capaces de poder expresar lo
que sienten Y eso también se contagia
para otro aspectos de su vida ellos
mismos dicen que se sienten que sienten
que el desarrollo de habilidades
sociales le ha permitido poder
desenvolverse de mejor manera con el
resto de de los espacios en los cuales
Ellos están Antonio y y muy buena obra
no también que ellos entiendan la
responsabilidad que tiene uno a la hora
de comunicar a la hora de pararse ante
una cámara que también pues no es para
todos no cuestión de valientes como dice
muchos pero hablemos ahora de la
retroalimentación o que han tenido de
esos docentes que trabajan también para
para para este canal
la verdad es que los profesores y
profesoras Mira primero que todo que
quiero decir de manera muy importante
que muchos profesores y profesores de
nuestra escuela están en un proceso de
evaluación docente este año y muchos de
ellos han incluido el Emilia TV como uno
de los recursos o los factores que le
permiten poder aportar de mejor manera a
su rol como docente Eso me parece ya muy
significativo porque significa que el
que el proyecto no solamente es
importante para los niños y niñas que
participan sino que también para los
docentes y yo creo que también
justamente algo que tú mencionabas los
profesores y profesores en tiempos de
pandemia tuvieron que mostrar una cara
distinta una cara desde desde las
videollamadas desde las transmisiones en
vivo y y el hecho de sumar semilla TV
también les ha aportado a poder mejorar
sus habilidades sociales sin duda porque
no es lo mismo estar dentro de una sala
con un curso a mostrarse al mundo a
exponerse Entonces ha sido positivo eso
también para ello Antonio también
tuvieron la visita del presidente
Gabriel Boris Y cómo fue Esta visita
primero que todo no sabíamos que venía
entonces fue una sorpresa una sorpresa
gigante para la comunidad fue un momento
muy muy bonito porque los niños y niñas
yo hubo mucha alegría mucha emoción
incluso algunos niños y niñas que
lloraron más allá de de de
la situación política para ellos que el
presidente de la república asista a su
escuela fue una situación
sorprendente inolvidable todavía lo
menciona todavía lo comentan muestran
las fotos que pudieron sacarse con él
fue un momento como comunidad muy
emocionante muy impactante y que todavía
nos sigue ahí dando vuelta en nuestra
retina y en nuestro corazón se puede
replicar o ya se está replicando este
formato de media también otras escuelas
chilenas otras escuelas de latinoamérica
yo creo que sí se puede pero él es
importante entender que le mira te ves
un canal es un medio lo que debemos
replicar en las escuelas no solo de
chile siento yo sino que el mundo es es
mirar la educación desde nuevos
paradigmas paradigmas que les permitan a
los niños y niñas ser los principales
protagonistas de su proceso de
aprendizaje ya debemos empezar a cambiar
Este modelo donde el docente es una
persona que habla frente a los demás y
los demás deben guardar silencio sino
que debemos crear espacios colaborativos
de aprendizaje donde los adultos sean
los facilitadores y los niños niñas sean
quedan quienes puedan gestionar de
manera guiada por supuesto su recursos
de aprendizaje sus habilidades el
desarrollo de su personalidad de sus
características propias de esta manera
ellos van a sentirse más motivados por
lo tanto lo que hay que replicar es este
cambio de paradigma